check these out
these are Google's answer to the Apple
web the LG watch sport and LG lifestyle
they're running Android wear 2.0 which
is Google's new SmartWatch platform and
it worked with LG on both of them
welcome back to Android wear 2.0 another
time but really all you need to know is
that it's way faster Google assistant is
great and it's a really good fitness
tracker right now let's talk about these
watches
I call them Beauty and the Beast first
Beauty the LG watch style I mean it's
right there in the name this thing is
here to prove that a SmartWatch can be
pretty and it is it's kind of nice
looking but it doesn't do anything
really
no fitness tracking since it can't track
your heart rate and doesn't have some
key sensors you can't use it to pay for
stuff it doesn't have NFC it's about as
powerful as a pebble and we saw how that
turned out it's definitely the most
normal looking Android wear watch ever
and that's saying something but you can
get a much nicer looking watch for 250
bucks the watch sport on the other hand
the Beast has all the features all of
them NFC heartrate payments you can put
a sim card in this thing and ditch your
phone forever but to get all of that you
have to wear a watch the size of a
hubcap
and recharge it every few hours if
you're a super Fitness person it might
be worth the 350 bucks because it's a
really great workout companion but
otherwise it's just way too much I feel
like there has to be some middle ground
here maybe a style with NFC or heartrate
so you can pay for stuff or maybe a
sport - the sim card and LTE so this
thing isn't the size of my car I get
that everybody wants a SmartWatch thit
those all the things they want it to do
and looks the right way and is
personalized just to them and for bands
and styles that's great but everybody
wants a SmartWatch that lasts multiple
days and everybody wants a SmartWatch
that code looks good and works well
Google and Apple and everybody else
they're still working on that stuff and
I get the sense right now it's just
impossible to put it all in one package
once they get there I will tell everyone
to buy a SmartWatch and if you buy one
of these you'll probably like it but you
don't need one yet